Ein Forschungsteam hat in Mittel-Australien
jetzt ein gigantisch großes Vulkangebiet
aufgespürt.
Mit 7.500 Quadratkilometern ist es doppelt
so groß wie Mallorca.
Und nicht nur das: Die rund Achtung!
100 neu entdeckten Vulkane haben sich auf
äußerst merkwürdige Art und Weise entwickelt.
Die Erkenntnisse könnten unser Wissen über
die Entstehung von Vulkanen revolutionieren.
Clixoom Science & Fiction - hier gibt es täglich
faszinierende Science/Videos zu, abonniert
den Kanal, aktiviert die Glocke!
Nur so verpasst ihr Nichts - Los geht’s!
herzlich willkommen!
Australien hat wirklich eine feurige Vergangenheit.
Die sogenannte Kalkarindji-Vulkanprovinz im
Westen war vielleicht sogar am ersten großen
Massensterben der Erdgeschichte beteiligt.
Erst vor kurzer Zeit hatten Forschungsteams
dann im Südosten von Australien die längste
kontinentale Vulkankette der Erde entdeckt.
Jetzt gibt es eine weitere super spannende
Entdeckung in diesem Zusammenhang: Ein Geologie-Team
hat jetzt nämlich im Untergrund von Mittel-Australien
mehr als 100 alte Vulkane aufgespürt.
Und diese sind wirklich nicht ohne: Dazu heißt
es in der aktuellen Studie: “Diese vulkanische
Provinz erstreckt sich über rund 7.500 Quadratkilometer“.
Vergleichbar also mit der Größe von Tirol
oder eben der doppelten Fläche von Mallorca.
Die Vulkane aus dem Jurazeitalter vor 160
bis 180 Millionen Jahren entwickelten sich
anders als es sonst bei den meisten Vulkanen
der Fall ist.
Statt an den Rändern einer Erdplatte nämlich
entwickelten sich die neu aufgespürten Vulkane
in der Mitte einer Erdplatte!
Eine Überraschung - auch für die Fachleute
selbst.
Dazu Simon Holford, der an der Studie beteiligt
war.
“Während die Mehrheit des irdischen Vulkanismus
an den Grenzen der tektonischen Platten unter
den Ozeanen stattfindet, liegt diese uralte
Vulkanwelt des Jura tief im Inneren des australischen
Kontinents.
Das verändert unsere Vorstellung davon, wie
solche Prozesse in der Vergangenheit der Erde
abliefen.
(...) „Wir interpretieren die Warnie-Vulkanprovinz
als Produkt der Dehnung und des innerhalb
der Platte stattfindenden konvektiven Aufströmens
von Gestein über der subduzierten Pazifischen
Platte“.
Heißes Magma hat sich also von der Pazifischen
Platte, die tief unter den Kontinent gedrückt
war, durch die darüber liegende Kontinentalplatte
gebrannt.
So konnten die neu entdeckten Vulkane also
entstehen.
Schon seit langer Zeit stoßen Fachleute am
sogenannten Cooper-Eromanga-Becken immer mal
wieder auf rätselhafte Funde.
Diese Senke hält vor allem Erdöl und Erdgas-Vorkommen
bereit, die schon seit Anfang der 60-er Jahre
für die Wirtschaft von Interesse sind.
Der Granit im Untergrund dieser Senke bietet
hervorragende Bedingungen für ein Geothermieprojekt,
das hier getestet wird.
Doch nicht nur das: Nicht nur Granit und Sedimentgestein
wurden hier immer mal wieder zutage gefördert,
sondern auch Basalt.
Dabei handelt es sich um Gestein vulkanischen
Ursprungs - zum Teil wohl aus der Trias, und
zum anderen aus dem Jura.
Doch warum sollte es in der Mitte der australischen
Kontinentalplatte vulkanische Aktivität geben?
Bislang war das eine kaum denkbare Vorstellung
für die Fachleute.
Schließlich bilden sich Vulkane dem bisherigen
Wissensstand nach eher an den Rändern einer
Erdplatte.
Das australische Forschungsteam hat jetzt
alle vorhandenen Daten zu dieser Region analysiert.
Dazu der beteiligte Wissenschaftler Jonathon
Hardman: “Es gibt enorme Mengen an Daten
aus dem Untergrund dieser Region.
Aber das Alter und die Natur dieser Basaltgesteine
waren größtenteils unbekannt.“
Aber auch seismische Messungen machten die
spektakuläre Entdeckung des riesigen Vulkan-Gebietes
möglich.
Somit steht jetzt fest: In dieser Region gab
es in vergangenen Zeiten heftige vulkanische
Aktivität.
Davon zeugen nicht nur die 100 Vulkane, sondern
auch ausgedehnte Lavaströme und weitere vulkanische
Ablagerungen.
Das Forschungsteam vermutet zudem auch, dass
es hier einst Geysire und heiße Quellen gab.
Dafür sprechen bestimmte geologische Strukturen,
die jetzt entdeckt werden konnten.
Die Analyse der Fachleute ergab, dass die
Vulkane wohl im Zeitalter des Jura aktiv waren:
also zuletzt vor 160 Millionen bis 180 Millionen
Jahren.
Von diesen Vulkanen geht also keine Gefahr
mehr aus.
Anders sieht das bei dem Vulkan Bolschaja
Udina im Osten Russlands aus.
Droht mega Vulkanausbruch mit katastrophalen
Folgen?
Anklicken, anschauen und Clixoom Science & Fiction
abonnieren, falls ihr es noch nicht getan
haben solltet.
Bis dann, bleibt dran!